[موسيقى]
الدور الجديد لقطاع السياحه السعوديه لا
يقتصر على زياده مساهمته في الاقتصاد فحسب
حيث يمتد الى سوق العمل وتوفير وظائف
نوعيه جديده للسعوديين من مستودعات القطاع
توفير مليون وظيفه مستحدثه بحلول 2030
ولكن كيف من الممكن تحقيق ذلك حسب بعض
التقديرات فان قطاع السياحه سيوفر وظيفه
من كل ثلاث وظائف في السعوديه خلال
السنوات ال 10 المقبله مع تركيز المملكه
على النهوض بالانشطه غير النفضيه
قد تبدو النسب كبيره لكن سوق العمل في
القطاع السياحي يشمل مجالات اوسع مما
يعتقده كثيرون
فبحسب تصنيف منظمه السياحه الدوليه فان
القطاعات التي تتبع منظومه السياحه هي
منشات الايواء والحركه السياحيه وخدمه
الطعام والمشروبات والنقل بكافه وسائله
وتاجيل معداته ووكلات السفر والحيز
والانشطه الرياضيه والترفيهيه اضافه الى
النشاط الثقافي وقطاع التجزئه
هناك 14 برنامج اساسيا في السعوديه لتنميه
القدره البشريه في القطاع السياحي حيث
تتنوع هذه البرامج لتشمل مختلف جوانب
العمل من المشاريع الصغيره ورياده الاعمال
الى المنشات الضخمه في القطع وقد تم في
يونيو الماضي اطلاق برنامج رواد السياحه
بهدف تدريب 100 الف شاب وشابه في قطاعات
الضيافه والسفر والسياحه وتتعاون مؤسسات
دوليه في توفير هذه البرامج مثل جامعه لرش
في اسبانيا وكليه اداره الفنادق السويسريه
وكليات الضيافه
البرامج التدريبيه الى اعداد المتدربين
لوظائف المستقبل مثل ما ساهمت مدرسه فرندي
الشهيره في باريس في اتاحه الفرصه
للمتدربين الطهاره للحصول على وظائف في
اداره الفنادق المنشات حديثا في العلا
وتمتاز العديد من هذه البرامج التدريبيه
بانها مجانيه بهدف مساعده اكبر عدد ممكن
من الشباب لتحقيق الطموحاتهم في القطاع
السياحي